now when you have a look at some of the
questions that you get they're not gonna
be nice and neat like this sometimes
this thing is gonna be disastrous and
expanding is just kind of like the Sun
is going to set and you're gonna get
hungry in what any dinner you like
forget this okay it's taken too long
okay
so expanding which is kind of like a
prerequisite for comparison of
coefficients is not the early way so
method two I'm going to give this method
a name in a second but I want you to
think about this for a second we're
dealing with quadratic functions right
quadratic functions now if I'm telling
you hey I'd like you to come up with a
quadratic function for me it's not
enough information to tell you here's a
point that that quadratic function goes
through because clearly there's an
infinite number of quadratics that go
through that point do you agree and we
could draw them very easily in fact I'm
going to make a mincemeat of this
diagram in a second here's a quadratic
that goes through and here's another one
and here's another one and here's
another one and it just goes on and on
and on
clearly one piece of information not
enough agree however even when I go up
to wrong color even when I go up to two
pieces of information like any two
points on the plane like say here and
under here there is still clearly an
infinite number of quadratics that go
through both these points can you start
to picture them look here's an obvious
one
whoops sorry he's an obvious one let's
try something like that that one goes
through use your imagination all right
that one goes through how about this one
that one goes through as well and then I
can make it's deeper I can make it go
through like that two piece of
information still one enough agreed but
I've got enough space just here
if you provide three pieces of
information and they can be anywhere
yeah yeah here now imagine again there's
only one quadratic that can go through
all three of the points right and you
can sort of start to see it right
where's the vertex going to be hmm I
think it's going to be a bit higher than
that top point up there just a bit above
because you can see the axis of symmetry
where it's gonna lie I guess it's
something like that hold on I'll fix it
wait there we go
good as new okay now you can you can go
through these experiment as many times
as you like the reason why you need
three pieces of information to get your
to firm down your quadratic is because
every quadratic is defined by count them
one two three numbers does this make
sense but ax squared plus BX plus C once
you know what a B and C are you've got
everything about it there's only a
single quadratic that looks like that
okay so therefore method two is called
three values I know it's a bit of an
awkward name but the idea is if you can
find three values where these two things
are equal any three values I could put
these anywhere I like so you have to be
a bit creative and imagine if when you
choose these then you should be able to
find what a B and C are equal to let me
show you how this unfolds I'm gonna
start back from this line this line here
okay because that is the quadratic
identity after which this is named okay
excuse me I'm going to start from this
line and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to choose some values that these
two things should be equal for right
they should be and then I'm gonna see
what happens there and I know I need
three I'm just going to choose a
convenient bunch okay so the first I'm
going to choose is and I'll let you
figure out why I choose this one in a
second
I'm only choose negative one
x equals negative one okay what I choose
negative one well if these two
quadratics are really the same quadratic
they're the same curve just looked at
from different points of view then this
statement should still be true for a
particular value of x in fact it should
be true for all the values of X right so
watch what happens when I substitute in
okay what do you get on the left-hand
side I'm pretty sure you get 2 minus 3
minus 6 that look okay yeah I substitute
it all right now apparently that should
be equal to sorry this is no longer
exactly because for certain values of a
B and C that should be equal to what
happens on the right-hand side what
happens to that first term he becomes 0
what about this one and then you just
get C you see why I chose negative 1 now
that wasn't just a coincidence I did it
in order to make it collapse as quickly
as I possibly could so now you can see
straight away from here that this is
minus 1 that's minus 6 so C is negative
7 like you already knew but this is
quite a different way to go about it do
you see so I've got a value I've only
found one of the premium rules that I
need to find the others so I need to
choose another value of x this is
completely up to me I really literally
can choose anything I could choose like
423 if I wanted I could choose PI
negative a million but I want to choose
easy numbers would you like to give me a
suggestion how about 0 if X is equal to
0 on the left hand side it looks like
I'm going to get 0 plus 0 minus 6 on the
right hand side what will I get a times
1 squared which is a plus because B
times 1 and then C but I know what C is
I know what C is so I've got negative 6
equals a plus B minus 7 yeah so I have
an equation I'm gonna give this a name
because clearly I don't have enough
information on its own right and the
reason why is because look this method
is called 3 values and I've only tried
out two so I need one more with someone
like to give me a suggestion I'm gonna
let X equal
you just want any any number that's nice
and easy okay I think here it's kind of
like a tie between 1 or negative 2 1 or
negative 2 okay one is nice and easy to
evaluate on this side see that negative
2 is a bit easier to evaluate on this
side it's much of a muchness okay
remember I can pick anything I'm gonna
go with ones just because less negative
signs son are probably a better idea for
me okay so when x equals 1 what is the
left-hand side 2 plus 3 take away 6 yep
right-hand side think this is a times
what now that's 2 squared which is 4
so that's going to be for a is that okay
this is 1 plus 1 which is 2 and then
there's C but I know what C is so I'll
just write it okay is that Alright 2
plus 3 minus 6 that's 5 minus 6 which is
negative 1 negative 1 I'm gonna add 7 to
both sides so that gives me this wedge I
say negative 1 I said the only one right
so I added 7 so it's 3 a 6 unit said
right that better yep I can simplify
that to a plus B that looks pretty good
I think that's ready what we're talking
to do with these I
I'll get the operation eventually I
think subtraction is probably the
easiest way to eliminate you can see
when I go to minus 1 that should just
give me the value of a straightaway
right 2 minus 1 is going to be equals 2
which you already knew you are in you
and if you sub that back into the first
equation this one here then B is going
to be negative 1 agreed okay now when
you compare the left hand side the right
hand side the board method 1 which is
comparison of coefficients method 2
which is 3 values okay pretty similar
amounts of
working maybe this is a little more it's
a little more what you'll find is that
method two becomes more and more
advantageous to you the more disastrous
this right-hand side hooks okay
because evenness this thing is a
disaster all you're doing is plugging in
values that doesn't really get much
harder okay whereas this started like
this process here all we had to do is
expand once you've spent twice and we
were there okay but if you've got like
fractions over here if these things are
more complicated this one is going to
start to balloon out and then it's easy
to make little errors and then you
compare the coefficients incorrectly so
you choose based on what B is
appropriate for the question does that
make sense
hmm the third method which I'm not going
to show you but I'm just going to tell
you what it is is to note that see how
you've got X plus ones instead of X's
right so what that means is this is a
quadratic that's been shifted what
direction has have been shifted in so
you can use that information that's all
you need that's all you need there are
all the information you were thinking
about with roots and some important that
kind of thing what Sharon mentioned
before you can do you can go through the
same exercise and find out what the new
quadratic is but that's a bit outside
the scope of the course so I'm just
gonna hit pause there okay